This episode is brought to you by Squarespace.
Go to squarespace.com/microcosmos to get a
free trial and 10% off your first purchase
of a website or domain.
We don’t know how many rites of
passage there are
institutionalized among
amateur microscopists.
But we do have to imagine, that as people find
themselves navigating the microcosmos for
the first time, they’re often on the lookout
for tardigrades.
Their funny appearance and legendary resistance
have made tardigrades icons of the microscopic
world, and who doesn’t love an icon?
Recently, our master of microscopes James
decided to try out a new way to gather tardigrades.
The method is simple, and the results quite
astounding.
All you  need is some mesh, water, and
a little bit of patience.
James has a little patch of moss next to his
trash bins.
So when he takes his trash out, he’ll sometimes
collect bits of the moss to look for microbes later.
And we have seen tardigrades from
these bits of moss before.
The question is, though, how to easily and
efficiently get the tardigrades to emerge
from the moss so that James can watch them
under the microscope.
Recently, James was inspired to try out something
called the Baermann funnel, which he’d found
in a book.
This technique goes back to at least 1917,
when it was first described by a Dutch physician
named Gustav Karl Theodor Friedrich Baermann.
He invented the method when he was in Java,
looking for nematodes that live in soils—
particularly parasitic hookworms.
And since then, the tool has become one of
several that nematode researchers use to gather
their research subjects, in part because it is
just so easy to set up.
Here we can see just how simple James’ version
is.
To make one of your own, start by placing
some soil or moss on a mesh fabric.
There’s a number of things you can use for
the mesh, including tea bags, a pair of
tights, or a cheesecloth.
Then place the mesh/moss combination into
a funnel and carefully add water until only
just part of the moss is dipped in the water.
Make sure to seal off the bottom of the funnel—
in James’ case, he used a piece of rubber
tube.
The next day, you can return to see what organisms
have gone through the mesh and are now settled
at the bottom of the funnel.
The Baermann funnel has proven to be a lasting
tool for nematologists to find worms buried
in soil.
They begin with the soil sample above the
mesh, and with the addition of water, the
worms are released from the soil.
This sets them free to travel to the mesh
and then through it, ultimately settling at
the bottom of the funnel.
And after anywhere from 16-72 hours, the nematologist
can return to find a bundle of microscopic
worms at the bottom.
But this doesn’t necessarily work for all
nematodes.
Nematodes that live in plants can take longer
to come out, while other species will travel
away from the bottom of the funnel.
So when James decided to try this technique
out to find tardigrades, there was no guarantee
that it would actually work.
He returned the day after setting up his tardigrade-trapping
apparatus and had to just hope for the best.
He collected a drop of water from the bottom
of the funnel and prepared a slide.
What he saw was incredible.
He counted 196 tardigrades on his very first
slide.
That is a lot of tardigrades!
If you try the Baermann funnel out and find
that your tardigrades are a bit hard to see
because bits of sediment or other things
floating in your sample, don’t worry, James
had this same issue too.
They’re kind of hard to make out here because
there’s just so much stuff for them to hide in.
He just washed the tardigrades a bit to make
them a little more presentable for us, carefully
pipetting drops of water until there was minimal
debris to obscure our view.
And one of the cool things about having caught
so many tardigrades at once is that you can
see how much variety there is to them.
Like here we have a few tardigrades that look
like giants crawling in a variety pack of
miniature tardigrades.
You can also catch tardigrades in some funny
situations, like this tardigrade that’s
using its clawed feet to walk along the glass
slide.
Tardigrades cannot swim, but they will use
their claws to walk around underwater.
And glass is a tough surface for this one
at the moment, but over time, it will get better—
though not because of anything the glass
or tardigrade does.
Over time, those little dots of bacteria you
see across the screen will accumulate.
And as the number of bacterias grow and spread
across the glass, their bodies will create
friction along the surface, which means the
tardigrade will be better equipped to walk
across it.
James also found this tardigrade who looks
trapped in a bag.
In reality, she’s stuck to her cuticle,
which is full of eggs that will one day hatch
and replenish the world of tardigrades.
So the Baermann funnel helped James find a
ton of tardigrades without much fuss.
But there’s one major thing he did have
to keep in mind: oxygen.
When he first added the moss to the funnel,
the tardigrades were in their resting tun
state, their entire being temporarily on pause
so they could survive the desiccated conditions.
And when James added water and created more
favorable conditions, the tardigrades emerged
from the tuns and began walking around.
So ideally, you will give the tardigrades
enough time to unfreeze themselves.
But if you wait too long, then the water in
the funnel begins to form an oxygen gradient.
The surface will have more oxygen, while the
bottom will have less.
And that’s a problem because that bottom
region is where the tardigrades end up
settling as we collect them through the mesh.
As more and more tardigrades
accumulate in that bottom area,
they will have to compete
with each other for oxygen.
And sadly, the oxygen concentration can change
very rapidly, killing the tardigrades before
they can even return to their protective tuns.
But there are a few ways to prevent the death
of your tardigrades.
Try and collect the tardigrades from the funnel
sooner rather than later.
It may take some trial and error to find the
right timing, but James says to try and avoid
waiting longer than a day.
And when James does collect his tardigrades,
he provides them with fresh water to replace
the oxygen-deficient
water they're living in.
He also adds some algae from his pond samples
into the slides and keeps them in transparent
humidity chambers under a light source.
The light helps the algae reproduce, providing
tardigrades with both food and oxygen.
These are the refinements that James has made
to the Baermann funnel to make it work for
his tardigrades.
And depending on what materials you have available
to you and the samples you’re collecting,
you might have to make your own creative adaptations.
The joy of the microcosmos is that it is
all around us, but it can also take time and
practice to figure out the best ways to actually
find its inhabitants.
So we hope this technique helps you all on
your own journey.
And if you try the Baermann funnel out on
your hunt for nematodes and tardigrades, make
sure to share what you find with us.
Thank you for coming on this journey with us as
we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
And thank you to Squarespace for sponsoring
this episode.
Squarespace gives people a powerful and beautiful
online platform from which to create their website.
So whether you’re looking to create an online
portfolio, start a blog, or open an online
store, Squarespace can help you out.
Maybe it’s finally time to start that podcast
you’ve been thinking about.
Well, you can use a blog page to publish and
syndicate a podcast with Squarespace.
You can even use your Squarespace blog to
create an RSS feed so listeners can use their
preferred podcast service to subscribe and
download a new episode.
And they make it super simple to categorize,
schedule, and share those blog posts as well.
Squarespace also makes it easy to keep in
touch with your listeners.
You can interact with your community on your
Squarespace site through threaded comments
and replies, and generate extra revenue
through members-only content.
And if you decide you want to start selling
some merch to go along with that podcast,
Squarespace also is a powerful ecommerce platform,
and you can even go the extra mile and create
third-party extensions to help you manage
inventory, streamline bookkeeping, and ship
products across the world.
You can sign up today for a free trial at
Squarespace.com.
And when you're ready to launch, visit squarespace.com/microcosmos
to get a free trial and 10% off your first
purchase of a website or domain.
The people on the screen right now, they are
our Patreon patrons.
They're the people who make it all work here
at Journey to the Microcosmos, so that we
can continue finding new ways to interact
with our world and sharing those ways with you.
I'm really excited to see if anybody else
goes ahead and builds a Baermann funnel to
capture hundreds of tardigrades.
If you want to become one of these people,
you can do that at Patreon.com/JourneytoMicro.
If you want to see more from our Master of
Microscopes, James Weiss, you can check out
Jam and Germs on Instagram.
And if you want to see more from us, there's
always a subscribe button somewhere nearby.